you have to work really hard if you
don't want to get anywhere with whatever
you do if you were called it off you're
gonna succeed I just kind of laugh when
I see people you know you know telling
me I've sold out or something like that
cuz I haven't changed anything I just
feel so happy you know that I'm one of
the few people you know you can actually
say that I you know I love what I'm
doing
leave motivation
watch a top ten of the leaf nation
what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out onto the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew on today's lessons from a
man who chose his stage name because his
real name was already taken on MySpace
and then he went on to become one of the
world's most popular and famous DJs he's
Avicii and here's my take on his top ten
rules of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one
make it happen my first got into making
music
it came kind of together went on lonely
the program first that was the music I
could make in the program before that I
didn't really listen to much that I find
music at all there was all the house
blogs I was always on on those websites
just get the latest music to kind of get
inspired really I in turn thought why
not try to send my songs to each house
box and see you know if they can promote
it or if they can you know Willie said
[Music]
my manager he messaged me on Facebook
and just said that he you know came
across my music and wanted to you know
meet up he's had a couple of ideas
that's what he kind of started getting
real I wanted to do music professionally
like as a career rule number two is give
it your all try to figure out where
you're most passionate about in life and
what you're good at and the mixture
between those two and then you should
give it your all all the time you
shouldn't you have to work really hard
if you want to get and you work with
whatever you do if you work hard enough
you're gonna succeed and that's that's
almost that's almost a fact I've seen it
so many times
rule number three just get started how
was the game changed with technology in
music well I mean you don't really need
anything anymore you need your computer
that's all you need you don't need any
any keyboards you don't need anything to
produce interviews if you know the
program like good quality music you know
and then obviously you're gonna have to
you know you have to know melodies and
you know what not everyone can learn
that but it's definitely made it easier
for so many people to get into this and
you know get started with it and and you
know a lot of people maybe that before
couldn't afford or didn't want to risk
buying hardware for in you know
thousands of dollars because they didn't
know if they could produce or not but
now it's like all for pretty much
nothing you can just download and it's
amazing things like GarageBand for
example exactly yeah or any of the pro
there's so many programs and you know
it's all about how you work with the
program as well so no it's it's just
amazing how how easy it is to get
started now rule number four is find
your path I actually just downloaded my
sequencer one night when I was at my
parents see like cottage in like my car
no no I like I like on our summer summer
vacation
thing and I had nothing to do and I have
trying to play the guitar and stuff like
that for like two years but I never got
really good at it and then I like read
on on the internet about a program where
you could paint your melodies oh my gosh
this is cool
so I kind of downloaded that and try
doing like a remix of an old track
called lazy lazy Jones or canker for
400-some the nation that ones I tried to
remix of that one and it ended up not
really being a remix just just an
original then I kind of got like stuck
from that cuz it's so cold in Sweden for
eight months out of 12 so there's not
that much to do so you're kind of forced
to to define something to do and I think
DJing and production is like it's the
perfect thing for people cannot escape
from the Swedish winter in a way and
because everyone has this dream to be
able to travel travel the world you know
and that can and since we've had so many
people coming from Sweden who has been
successful already it doesn't feel that
far-fetched to be able to make it you
know I mean because people like Steve
Angello Sebastian Ingrosso acts well but
you know all these other house producers
have already made it so it's so easy for
people to like I could do that as well
you know what I mean I think that's why
there's so many people doing it in
Sweden rule number five laugh at critics
what do you think of the tractors that
attempt to claim your sound is too
mainstream
um I mean everyone has 30 as her own
music tapes I don't know I haven't
changed my sound a bit from when I
started to know in order to please the
mainstream I've always been doing the
music I'm doing now I always stay true
to myself and you know like the music
has become more popular and you know the
mainstream has open out
instrumental tracks and stuff like that
and I've always been interesting and
doing these kind of like really melodic
uplifting tracks so I you know when I I
just kind of laugh when I see people you
know you know telling me I've sold out
or something like that because I haven't
changed anything you know so I was
wondering do you find it bothersome
little when people say things like that
because as you said you've been creating
the same sound for a very long time so
you haven't changed the only thing that
has changed as more people have
discovered you so does it feel weird to
have people essentially hating on your
success yeah I mean it's in the
beginning it bothered me because you're
like oh yeah I want to tell this person
that it's not like that you know like
are you you know kinda like are you
stupid just look at you know mom you see
then I look at my music now but then you
know there I used to notice the better
things go like everyone said the more
haters you get like by default
and I mean you can't say it to everyone
and I mean it doesn't really matter
anyway so right now I just felt like
brush it off and don't really care that
much but obviously it's it's it's an
annoying thing but it's just something
you have to overlook rule number six
find your creative process
[Music]
I'd say it's the number one most
important thing every demo that we did
started out as an acoustic version so
like we'd come up with a song from
scratch and then we do do it with just
like a vocal and a piano and then I'd
take those parts with me home and then
I'd make something of that when it comes
to production and then this samples I
use for my cakes and then drums and
stuff like that I've kind of narrowed it
down enough now I've done and so much
from from my friends and you know in the
scene to we kind of share like the best
samples and stuff so I kind of have like
a folder with you know these are the
best songs that have you know all the
night long
rule number seven is find your
inspiration like I could find the
inspiration from like if I hear if I
hear we're really good house rock for
instance I can be like god this would be
cool but you could do it like this and
say you know what I mean so you get like
inspiration but then again you get
inspiration from all types of musics
really I mean you can get Alyssa to know
right Ray Charles track and get really
inspired by by like just a certain
rhythm or whatever you know and then try
to make something out of that and try to
make it into your own thing inside rule
number eight is surround yourself with
great people
I feel really fortunate that I've been
surrounded by so many good people my
manager and
that's been with me from the start and I
think that's it's really important when
Ash discovery first I didn't really know
how to DJ you know I was focusing on
producing music and making music so I
like I didn't even know how I was gonna
format if I was gonna perform in any way
for me to perform it when I met her she
just took it to a whole nother level
like professional like when I'm and he
really took me out of nowhere and then
really built my career and I couldn't I
wouldn't be here without that rule
number nine my personal favorite is love
what you do I just feel so happy you
know that I'm one of the few people who
you know can actually say that I you
know I love what I'm doing and I've
gotten to the point where I'm at today
you know it's I it's amazing like I
still can't believe it so you've
essentially made it what's next on the
agenda for Avicii just keep I mean keep
doing and keep building it for for as
long as I can and for for as long as I'm
still as long as I'm still loving it you
know which is essentially what's been so
the most important thing for me since
day one
and rule number ten the last one before
the bonus is have fun blondes or
brunettes
wall
do you like to sing just in the shower
anything I sing yeah - my to myself no
one hears ya I probably I really like
actually I like being in the studio when
no one hears me and I guess a good stuff
yeah every time I write stuff I try to
but I can't do it in front of anyone
because I feel like I get super nervous
and super shy straight away I'll sing it
right do you want to sing something
right now yeah absolutely not oh yeah
you're not gonna get me with that no way
no way that's wasn't it in for me to try
to do this
all right I got some special Avicii
bonus clips for you but before getting
to that my question of the day is around
rule number nine love what you do I want
to know what is the thing that you love
to do most in your business what is the
thing that gets you super pumped up and
alive leave it down the comments below
I'm looking forward to hearing from you
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clips
I started out with what FL Studio
I started leaking stuff on blogs
basically because it was easier and it
was easy to get the just how do you say
when you're the the tension because it's
hard to get labels when you're unknown
you know so I can start leaking stuff
and I got found by my manager
I used to mail the owners of the blog
and and just I mean like here here's my
music you know do you like it and you do
you want to would you it would be okay
to put it on the blog and stuff like
that and then they basically because for
every blogger it seems like they love
the promotion aspect of it because they
don't want just the music either they
want to like feel like they were doing
something
I mean good so they say so they gave a
lot of feedback I like how this real kid
look this is my space you know look at
these tracks and stuff like that so next
up is the DJ had my tea this evening I'm
a huge fan
he's amazing get ready for a beachy
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people need
passion and not one drop of myself work
depends on Europe it's something to me I
don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details